apparently Amazon are planning to do a
Stargate straight to cinema movie
and they're giving it a budget of 70 to
80 million dollars
is that enough
welcome to side track your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
now I've been told now for quite a long
time that Amazon were actually planning
a Stargate movie this has been then
confirmed by um industry Insider Jenny
stiven and actually by deadline who
actually spoke to Amazon representatives
and got this story about how they were
doing RoboCop they were doing Legally
Blonde three oh I can't wait for that
and that they were going to be doing a
Stargate movie probably
now that's slightly non-committal but at
the time there were still a lot of
voices inside MGM and Amazon arguing
over what is the best way to handle the
franchise and apparently those arguments
is still going on there's quite a lot of
infighting and nobody can quite decide
what they want to do but Jennifer salkey
the person in charge is very keen to do
a Stargate movie and it tends to be what
the boss wants the boss gets so we'll
see what happens
but while the strikes are going on and
everything we're not expecting any
announcements but the development work
is still going on but one of the things
the development team needs to know when
they're trying to figure out what to do
with the Stargate franchise and what
sort of movie they can produce is they
need to know what sort of budget they
can expect now this work has been done
repeatedly MDM did a lot of this work
before on while they were waiting for
Amazon sale to go through and they were
looking at something like eight or nine
million dollars an episode when Mark
Fergus and Hawk Osby first came and
first started negotiating with Amazon
they were asking for 10 million dollars
an episode to produce the TV series
Amazon came back with a figure of eh
maybe we'll pay five and they were in
the process of negotiating
I actually think that any TV production
now would probably have a budget of
around seven million dollars an episode
because a lot of streaming services are
shrinking their budgets you look at Star
Trek is cost between 9 and 11 million
dollars an episode
those sort of budgets are not going to
happen in future the chances are unless
the show is massively popular it's not
going to get that sort of money so a
Stargate franchise with about seven
million dollars an episode I think that
would be a budget we would get something
really really good out of
the expanse used to have a budget of
three to five million dollars an episode
all those years ago and that's you know
finished now so I think about seven
million dollars would be would be good
but a movie is what we're going to be
getting first now my sources are telling
me that a working budget of 70 to 80
million dollars has been agreed but
I was also told with the caveat that I
shouldn't be too worried about that my
first thinking was the Batgirl movie
that they just scrapped last year they'd
already spent 80 million dollars
the He-Man movie that Netflix just
scrapped had already spent 30 million
dollars they hadn't even started filming
so a budget of 70 to 80 million dollars
doesn't sound like a lot of money if we
really want a big budget sci-fi movie
now if you haven't got a lot of special
effects if you haven't got big sound
stages and big sets 78 million 70 to 80
million dollars is a lot of money you
can do a lot of movie for that but if
you do want CGI you do want big special
effects you do want big sets
then 70 80 million dollars isn't a lot
of money
but I was told not to panic because
basically this is just part of the
negotiation process and the filmmaking
process
the business people have come up with a
rough estimate of what they are willing
to spend right now the development team
will then take that and they will use
that as a benchmark when they're
developing the story ideas trying to
figure out how Grand this story can
actually be there is absolutely no point
in them developing a story that has a
massive Space Battles at the end if they
just don't have the budget to pay for it
so this is an initial round of basically
negotiations this is giving the
production company an idea of their
working budget now don't forget this is
not including them promotion or any of
those sort of costs this is just how
much money to actually make the film I'm
told though that the budget that is
there normally agreed after the
development process normally goes up so
I actually think if they're talking
about 70 to 80 million dollars now we're
probably looking more at 100 million
dollars to actually make the film
and remember this is a film that
hopefully will have a lot of the actors
returning from the series I mentioned
that because none of those are going to
demand 20 million dollars unless of
course we get Rowan and back so yeah
unless Jason Momoa is going to be in
this movie which you should be they
should at least ask him I'd love a Ronin
movie that to me would be the way to do
it and that film should get like 200
million dollars because to be honest it
would make it it's gonna get like an
a-lister at the moment you want like you
want Jason Momoa but the chances are he
won't be returning to the Stargate
franchise we won't be getting a Ron and
Dex movie
and instead we're probably going to
maybe get Amanda Tapping Michael Shanks
people like this back and they do not
command those sorts of fees so it's all
good for the budget
to be honest because they know they have
a working budget of this I doubt they'll
even consider Jason Momoa returning
because this isn't as I say a massive
budget considering some movies like the
Barbie movie had a combined total budget
of something like 300 million dollars
now apparently about half of that was
just for the advertisement the you know
media campaign that's gone with the
movie but still the film that didn't
have loads of CGI Etc still cost 150
million dollars to make
mostly because of the big A-list actors
that were in it but it's still cost a
crapload of money to make so this
working budget of 70 80 million dollars
I think it's a good start I think it'll
give the development team a really good
idea of what they can and can't do it is
enough money to produce something
exciting still if they're very clever
about how they spend it but yes I would
like them to spend a little bit more
please thank you very much
I'd be like Oliver please give me more
here's another 20 million go on you know
you want him
guys get into the comments don't tell me
what you think is this a budget that you
think could work is it at least a good
starting point for them to then bounce
off or do we need more money they keep
talking about this I mean Jenny staven
has mentioned this day who is a big
industry Insider and knows a lot about
what's going on in Stargate she's been
talking about how Amazon want this to be
a tent pole project that's what she
called it something that Amazon are
actually really willing to put their
money behind
they spent how much on rings of power
so how much might they spend on Stargate
what until a number do you think is
necessary for us to get the sort of
movie that we think we want I'd love to
know what you think get into the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small fee
you can get to see them without the
adverts you even get a free gift after
three months you can't argue with that
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]